this video is brought to you by privacy
calm which lets you buy things online
using virtual cards protecting your
identity and bank information on the
Internet Apple just announced the latest
edition of the best selling SmartWatch
and the question most of us are having
is if it's actually worth upgrading from
a series 4 or a series 3 since they are
both very capable devices especially
with watch OS 6 which is about to launch
I've upgraded my Apple watch basically
every year but it seems like the series
5 has the least amount of changes year
to year since I can really remember so
much so that this year Apple actually
decided not to sell the previous gen for
a lower price but instead they
discontinued it and now they're still
selling the series 3 a half the price of
series 5 now I've actually ordered my
series 5 and we will be making a
detailed comparison as soon as we get
our hands on them so make sure to
subscribe and enable notifications down
below so you don't miss out in that
video along with our full detailed
review now one brand new edition is the
new titanium model which comes in two
finishes and as a comeback we once again
have the ceramic model which I really
liked so for those that are stuck with a
series three because of the ceramic
model that you love you will likely want
to make the upgrade now in fact I will
just put it right out there if you own a
Series three and you're considering
upgrading I absolutely would there were
so many updates from the series three to
the four which of course are now carried
over to the new one you'll get a big
design change with a rounder sleeker
design and larger displays with rounded
corners the bottom is thinner and all
glass and the side button is flush with
the crown providing haptic feedback
sensors are more accurate
there's fall detection and you could
take ECGs which can now be used in
different apps like rocket body even
though battery life is rated the same I
had a noticeable improvement moving to
the series four from the three and I
expect that series 5 will actually be
better in the real world and that's
likely thanks to the new S 5 processor
which is more efficient and because of
that processor things will be noticeably
snappier as well now one big improvement
will be being able to use Siri by just
raising your wrists and talking I rarely
use Siri on my watch before the series
for because I was just slow and
cumbersome but
this feature makes it much more usable
the same thing goes for the speaker
that's 50% louder and along without a
better mic as I said before you should
definitely upgrade from the series 3 now
what about the rest of us who made the
big jump last year are the extra
features worth upgrading well for me
personally yes but before I tell you why
let me tell you about something else
that is absolutely worth it and not just
for me but for everyone and that's our
sponsor privacy calm in a time where
credit card data breaches seem to be the
new norm privacy calm makes it extremely
easy to use virtual cards to protect
your identity and bank information
completely free sign up a privacy calm
slash Mac stack and you can quickly
create virtual card numbers that are
locked to whatever merchant you shop at
so even if it's hacked they won't be
able to use them elsewhere you can even
make one-time use cards which are great
for single payments trials that require
cards or for sketchy sites and you can
set a variety of limits so you'll never
be billed twice or upgraded to another
service there chrome extension makes it
easy to use by Auto filling your card
info and unlike credit card companies
privacy does not sell your data but
keeps it safe using military-grade
encryption and is held to the same
standards as banks not only is it
completely free but if you sign up today
you will get five dollars for free like
literally if you're gonna be buying an
Apple watch for anything else take the
30 seconds to sign up a privacy calm
slash max tag or by using the link down
below just start keeping your personal
info safe and give five dollars towards
your first purchase now I absolutely
love my Apple watch and it's probably
the biggest thing that is locking me
into using an iPhone but my biggest
complaint has been the display that
shuts off not only does this look worse
than an actual watch with a face but at
times that could be very inconvenient
having to lift up your wrist and look
before it turns on and shows you your
notifications or the time now I
understood why Apple made this design
choice when I bought the series zero
because the battery life was terrible
but throughout the years it kept getting
better and I can now use my series 4 for
two full normal days so that was no
longer an excuse now before the event
the only thing I really
really wanted from the series five was
an always-on display not only did Apple
finally deliver on this but instead of
it just being a software option that
will end up really impacting battery
life they created a whole new display
technology called low-temperature
polycrystalline oxide which allows the
display to refresh at as low as one
frame per second which is perfect for a
SmartWatch now you'll have all of your
info at a glance and when you lift it up
the display will just get brighter the
newly updated ambient light sensor
should also help with this the next
hardware upgrade is 32 gigabytes of
storage that is included with even the
base models double what the series 4 has
so if you felt limited by how much apps
photos and music you could keep on your
watch this will be a welcome addition
but for me personally 16 gigabytes was
more than enough
the last major addition is the compass
which will do things like indicating the
direction you're facing which helps with
navigation and showing true north in the
new compass app which also displays
incline elevation latitude and longitude
and along with that series 5 will also
get a Meridian watch face personally I
don't really have a big need for this
but I can definitely see this feature
being very enticing for some people and
that is it those are really the only
major updates Apple did introduce the
watch studio and some new bands of
course but you can buy those separately
so to wrap it all up if you own a series
3 absolutely upgrade but if you already
own the very capable series 4 I think
that most people should probably keep it
for another year that is unless you're
like me and really really want to have
an always-on display or you can really
benefit from having a compass let me
know if you'll be upgrading to the
series 5 down in the comments section
below
or if not what you're using and why make
sure that you're subscribed and you have
notifications enable so you guys don't
miss out on a full review of the series
5 and our hands-on comparison there's
been max with max tech and I will see
you in the next video
[Music]